ROB DODSON: Hey, everybody.
What's up?
It's Rob Dodson
here at I/O 2015.
I just got done with my
sessions, and holy cow,
there was so much at
this year's event.
On the web platform,
we got stuff
for Service Worker,
Push Notifications,
and Add to Homescreen.
And my personal favorite,
Polymer 1.0, rolled out.
So if you're interested
in Polymer or any
of the other stuff that
we've been talking about,
you can catch all of it on
the Google Developers YouTube
channel.
I've got a show on there
called Polycast, where
we recap all the
latest cool stuff
with Polymer, LazyWeb, for what
happened last week on the web.
We've also got HTTP 203
and Totally Tooling Tips.
So a lot of really great
stuff to catch there.
Also, all the Sandbox
talks from I/O this year
are being recorded and posted
to the YouTube channel as well.
We've got a whole summer of
DevBytes for you to check out.
So you can catch up
on all the I/O content
that you missed out on.
It's great seeing you.
I'll catch you on the
YouTube Developers channel.
Be sure to click that
little subscribe button.
And I'll see you later.
[MUSIC PLAYING]